Inverness is a fast-growing City and the
restaurant market is clearly thriving
795 [ __ ] sheep in early summer menu 2
courses 995 I've asked looook to serving
dinner from his a la carte menu which
cost 34 pound for two courses without
team in there and the produce in the
fridge is to die for
so should be great you know this one and
that she's been in canapes and a pre
starter
this is ambitious food for London let
alone Inverness potato soup with wasabi
very creamy very very rich I'm excited
about the food but I don't feel
comfortable sitting here
you're like a painter you need he did
not you need a good I do like the paint
he will put something like black air and
not here because for him doesn't look
right very complicated a lot of a lot of
combinations of flavors going on for me
the golden rule is always keep it simple
you're tasting that broad bean and white
asparagus and the citrus vinaigrette the
confit tomato fennel seeds fennel
flowers chervil salad in parmesan there
must be 20 things going on this plate
and then that looks fantastic but
next up duck under service duck they
decided to make it for a journey
undermine a good 10 to 12 flavors on the
plate again it's just confused and your
mind is sort of working overtime to try
and understand what's happening
okay service business a main course
served in two parts
that's just pretentious almost like
someone is uncontrollable and almost
like a little bit carried away and and
overexcited and nothing saying to stop
come back oh is that all for me
yes Louis seems desperate to impress
next he'll be telling me how to eat it
find me the order you've got the
tiramisu first studies then the floating
island been so big finally the copy
throw a denominator well that it bonds
next one we told what's that detection
to appear because of the [ __ ] salmon
in the river
technically flavors were amazing the
scallops were delicious the light
vinaigrette and didn't need the parmesan
that need the flowers and do you need
that many flavors to make it work I want
changing this you and a flavor icing the
way we work the product
bring to the guests two flavors and I
want your personality has to be
comfortable on the plate and I see a lot
of uneasiness on the plate I don't know
if you're confident enough for what
you're doing and I've got to be very
honest because this is very crucial but
this is this has to work